اصوات المدافع الاوكرانيه المدعومه من
فنلندا في حربها مع روسيا ليست كافيه
للفنلنديين لابداع دعمهم في الصراع
الدائره
وسائلهم على قضاء في المدافع تسجل
استمراريه وتصميم لهذا الدعم منصه فنلنديه
غير ربحيه تدعس دوت كوم تعلن السماحه لدعم
القوات الاوكرانيه بالتوقيع وكتابه رسائل
على الذخائر الاوكرانيه ثم اعادت نشرها في
ما بعد
التوقيع مقابل الدعم المالي ما بين 200
دولار امريكي الى 500 قيمه لوضع اسماء
ورسائل الفلنديين على قضاء في المدفعيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ووفقا لصحيفه التايمز البريطانيه فان
المواقع الالكترونيه المشابهه والمتخصصه
بالتبرع لاوكرانيا جمعت مئات الالاف من
الدولارات منذ اطلاقها فيما تحظى فنلندا
بالنصيب الاكبر من هذه التبرعات
قلق المواطنين الفنلنديين من ان تطال
بلادهم نيران الحرب الروسيه عكسته ارقام
اليها التايمز حيث دعى ثمانيه وخمسون في
المئه من الفنلنديين الى رفع ميزانيه
البلاد العسكريه كما اعرب
85% عن قلقهم بشان تصعيد روسي المتزايد
تحرك فيلنديين بالتبرع والتوقيع على
القذائف الاوكرانيه يتزامنوا مع مواجهتهم
ازمه طاقه فبعد ما اعتمدت فنلندا على ثلث
احتياجاتها من روسيا الان تقترب من الرقم
صفر الامر الذي يجعل تفسيرا لمواجهه
فرنديين للسقيع برسائل القذائف الاوكرانيه